whatever the mind can conceive and
believe
it can achieve
every adversity
every failure
every heartache
carries with it the seed of an equal or
greater benefit
if you can't do great things
do small things in a great way
when your desires are strong enough you
will appear to possess superhuman powers
to achieve
[Music]
wise men
when in doubt
whether to speak or to keep quiet
give themselves the benefit of the doubt
and remain silent
do not wait
the time will never be just right
start where you stand
and work whatever tools you may have at
your command
and better tools will be found as you go
along
set your mind on a definite goal
and observe how quickly the world stands
aside to let you pass
the way of success
is the way of continuous pursuit of
knowledge
you may be hurt if you love too much
but you will live in misery if you love
too little
a quitter never wins
and a winner never quits
the man who does more than he is paid
for will soon be paid for more than he
does
our only limitations are those we set up
in our own minds
happiness is found in doing
not merely possessing
don't wait
the time will never be just right
when defeat comes
accept it as a signal that your plans
are not sound
rebuild those plans
and set sail once more toward your
coveted goal
more gold had been mined from the mind
of men
than the earth itself
a goal is a dream with a deadline
cherish your vision and your dreams as
they are the children of your soul
the blueprints of your ultimate
achievements
when you are able to maintain your own
highest standards of integrity
regardless of what others may do
you are destined for greatness
put your foot upon the neck of the fear
of criticism by reaching a decision
not to worry about what other people
think
do or say
perhaps we shall learn
as we pass through this age
that the other self
is more powerful than the physical self
we see when we look into a mirror
there are no limitations to the mind
except those that we acknowledge
if you do not conquer self
you will be conquered by self
you've got to be sure of yourself before
you can ever win a prize
neglecting to broaden their view has
kept some people doing one thing all
their lives
persistence
is to the character of man
as carbon is to steal
any ideas plan or purpose
may be placed in the mind through
repetition of thought
remember that it is not the lawyer who
knows the most law
but the one who best prepares his case
who wins
if you must speak ill of another do not
speak it
write it in the sand near the water's
edge
weak desires bring weak results
just as a small amount of fire
brings a small amount of heat
most great people have attained their
greatest success just one step beyond
their greatest failure
desire is the starting point of all
achievements
not a hope
not a wish but a keen pulsating desire
which transcends everything
most so-called failures
are only temporary defeats
effort
only fully releases its reward
after a person refuses to quit
fears are nothing more than a state of
mind
every man is what he is
because of the dominating thoughts which
he permits to occupy his mind
desire backed by faith
knows no such word as impossible
it is your responsibility to make sure
that positive emotions constitute the
dominating influence
of your mind
control your finances
lack of them will control you
opportunity
it often comes disguised in the form of
misfortune
or temporary defeat
the capacity to surmount failure without
being discouraged
is the chief assets of every person who
attains outstanding success
in any calling